moment c'est parti pour une heure de
pédicure pas comme les autres théo et
apprentis maréchal ferrant il doit
ferrer pas moins de quatre chevaux par
jour tout en composant avec le poids de
l'animal qui frôle souvent les 600 kg un
métier physique et rigoureux dont il est
tombé amoureux il ya trois ans à la fin
un métier qui reste très manuelle mais
aussi pour demande beaucoup de réflexion
pour moi tout est aussi important à la
fois la théorie que la pratique au
niveau du ferrage que de là franchement
il faut d'abord retiré le g faire
enlever le surplus de cornes avant de
battre à nouveau faire à la forge et le
poser sur le pied du cheval des gestes
simples en apparence mais qui exige de
connaître l'anatomie de l'animal sur le
bout des doigts
on n'est pas juste des poseurs de faire
on prend pas justin faire qu'on va
mettre son pied du cheval il ya vraiment
tout une recherche toute une théorie à
savoir et appliqué voilà effectivement
ça peut vous paraître assez peut-être
assez simple pour vous mais dans notre
tête il ya plein de questions qui se
posent à ce moment là pourquoi je vais
faire ça à tel endroit comment je vais
le faire etc
et oui c'est que c'est complètement ça
on fait vraiment la solution sur mesure
et le maître n'est jamais loin pour
reprendre l'apprenti si ce métier
connaît un regain d'activité depuis
quelques années 4 maréchaux ferrants sur
10 met fin à leur carrière plus tôt que
prévu c'est un métier passion à toute
façon pour faire ce métier et durer dans
ce métier si on n'est pas passionné par
ce qu'on fait c'est même pas la peine
d'y penser
aimer les chevaux et mais ce qu'on va
faire
parce que c'est un métier très dur
physiquement on se brise pour l'heure un
vieux métiers qui a de l'avenir
membre de l'équipe de france théaux va
concourir dans quelques jours aux
championnats du monde de maréchalerie en
angleterre